ja mein vortrag handelt für der frage
inwiefern
kollektive personen
lebensformen sind und genauer genommen
lebensformen zweiter stufe
der vortrag ist hervorgegangen aus einer
habilitationsschrift nicht kürzlich in
münchen eingereicht habe und eine
gewisse form von exkurs darstellt wo ich
meine theorie der personal lebens von
die individuell ist auf kollektive
personen übertragen das möchte ich heute
zur diskussion stellen wer dazu ein
bisschen groß holen nämlich erst was
eben sagen zur konstitution
individueller personen dann auf die
individuelle personale lebensform
eingehen dann über gehen auf kollektive
personale lebensformen und
ausblick etwas sagen zum normativität
von kollektiv personen wie sie sich aus
meiner konzeption von lebensformen von
personaler lebensformen gibt also dass
es so wieder für das programm wenn meine
these ist wir können erst dann die
identität kollektiver personen genau
bestimmen wenn die identität der
individuellen person stimmt haben aus
denen sich kollektive personen
zusammensetzen als wäre so ein bisschen
die gegenthese von der eintritt
zu dem vortrag ich setze ganz stark von
der individuellen person an geht davon
aus anders formuliert identitäts
bedingung kollektiver personen müssen
und köln aus die liquiditätsbedingungen
individueller person heraus entwickelt
werden genaugenommen individuellen die
lebensform personalräten zuvor werden
noch genauer sagen was darunter zu
verstehen ist jetzt gehe ich ein
bisschen auf den forschungscontainer auf
die diskussion ein die sich um diese
debatte von individuellen personen dreht
die frage was wir eigentlich sind und
worin uns realität besteht wird in der
philosophischen debatte ontologisch ganz
unterschiedlich beantwortet
manche thesen manche theoretikerin
theoretiker vertreten die these wir das
was uns ausmacht
das ist der tierische organismus wir
sind wesentlich essentiell unsere die
testbedingungen
hängen von den organismen ab die uns
konstruieren wir sind menschliche tiere
da sagte animalis muss eine andere
antwort auf die folge was wir wesentlich
eigentlich sind wäre wir sind
selbstbewusst wie es kurz formuliert
dass es dieser neologismus beginnt auf
john block dann gibt es noch eine sehr
interessante dritte position es gibt
natürlich noch viel mehr die drei
scheinen wir ökologisch besonders
zentral zu sein die these wir sind
selbstbewusster wesen die durch ihren
körper organismus
konstituiert werden
das ist die konstitution steaks so und
jetzt gibt es hier ein meister argument
des animismus das ist also ein argument
das sehr sehr viele theoretiker den
theoretiker vertreten also die these
dass wir wesentlich menschen die tiere
sind es geht folgendermaßen mit einem
city new york
university nyu chase sinken
citynews
das ist dieses meister argument von
oracle zu also wir unsere identität
bedingungen selbst wenn wir denken kann
usw kognitiv präsenzen sind eben die man
noch tierisch organisch zu verstehen wir
können noch so viele denken wir werden
dadurch keine denkende substanz und so
weiter und so fort das ist dieses
argument und jetzt gehe ich auf lok 1
gegen denen sich auch ein bisschen
dieses meister argument wende noch mehr
natürlich auch dann gegen die
konstruktions theorie schon lockt
unterscheidet bekanntlich zwischen drei
formen von identität und ihren
prinzipien
erstens
substanz substanz versteht ja eigentlich
nur als aggregat also als zusammen loser
zusammenschluss von teilchen und wenn
ein teilchen fehlt diesen dieser
substanz dann ist es schon nicht mehr
dieselbe substanz
das ist also ein bisschen spezieller
substanz begriff dann sein also der
mensch das ist dann ungefähr das was der
animismus vertritt dass es die identität
des lebens der organismus der sich
vorantreibt und der nicht abhängig ist
von der einzelnen teil zusammensetzung
von dir von reformen die er die kirche
integriert also hier kann ein teilchen
wegfall diesen trotzdem noch derselbe
mensch das im organismus und dann gibt
es eine steigerung hin zur person die
person ist durch selbstbewusste
charakterisiert und gar nicht mehr
abhängig von der substanz
dieses selbstbewusstsein hat als unser
selbstbewusstsein kann sich
manifestieren ganz verschiedenen
substanzen
er könnte könnte auch einen kleinen
finger wandern zeigt ihr also identitäts
bedingung der person ist nicht ihre
organische substanz sollen das
selbstbewusstsein unserer erinnerung so
weit wie die erinnerung reicht so weit
reicht unsere identität zeigt anstelle
person substanz james tenney von three
different an die ist und dementsprechend
auf wie geht s prinzipien jetzt ist eben
dieses problem der frage nach dem
verhältnis von man und personen also
menschliche organismus und personen wie
ist dieses verhältnis zu denken da
arbeitet sich die ganze aktuelle debatte
um die konstitution person denn die kate
hat man es eben auch die konzentrations
theorie die vom berater becker besonders
präsent gemacht wurde schließt hier an
wenn auch nicht genau im sinne der
location theorie sagt constitucion
isabelle
generations of the world des
relationship
kulturbetrieben kein happy-end
warriors betrieb pieces of metal traffic
signs die angels and pieces of paper ein
dollar wird face of basic i don't
consider special i consider den
fundamentals of concept ist wenn aufwand
räumlichkeit ist circumstances sänger
von the primary care new thing you
kaufen powers kamps tricks ist also
konstruktions relation gilt verlinkt
nicht nur für personen und ihre sie
konstruierten am körper organismen
sondern eben für alle möglichen
phänomene auch unsere kulturellen welt
jetzt wendet sich diese konstitution
story von den bäcker vor allem gegen den
animalis mucks von recall sind besonders
prominent vertreten sie sagt nämlich
jetzt collington überlisten er ist nur
unter leute christink
bei consulting wird mir der physik hotel
als der pott ist fundamental wie kein
doping der post zu hören der baut dort
ist signifikant was also hier sieht man
jetzt bei bk dass sie sagt der animalis
muss auch wenn er unsere identität
ziemlich scharf begründet und logisch
dem fehlt nämlich könnte man sagen
sondern diese normative aus wir sind als
personen nicht nur lebewesen weil das
ist die identität von würmern sondern
unsere identität scheint eine gewisse
form von normalität beinhalten die nicht
aufgeht im bloßen körperlich
organschäden
weiteres zitat und constitucion view mit
personal person liste cup asse titel
first person perspektive und manager
human größen als junges team
konzentriert bei welchem organist also
die erste person perspektive das ist das
was ich von john blog leid das ist das
was daneben den bloßen organischen
körper zur person erhebt die frage ist
eben nur wie ist das verhältnis von
organischen körper zu personen die
dieses selbstlob senat und constitucion
will sagt sie bis die terminals
konditions und animal ist yogi tea
trails
person spray systems konnten also die
konstitution these sagt dass die person
die identitäts bedingungen vorgibt
der animismus sagt dass das was die
identität einer person ausmacht neben
der tierischen organismus hier
unterscheiden sich diese zwei theorien
grundsätzlich hinsichtlich ihrer
identität prinzipien
und jetzt noch ein zitat constitucion
joel stevie award 3d entwickelt genutzte
konstituiert das ist die entscheidende
tesa der sich auch die ganze debatte
einig aufhängt wir sind nicht identisch
diesen lebendigen organismen die uns auf
konstituieren aber wie ist dann dieses
verhältnissen leben zudem wenn es keinen
tag ist dieser konstitution ist relation
auf unity unity without identität
also wir sind wie gehen eine einheit als
person mit unserem körper organismus ein
untrennbarer aber nicht identisch zu
nahe an identität numerische und wie es
nur geht aber doch nicht identität weil
dann werden wir ja wieder auf der seite
des anhängers
so und jetzt kann man sich denken diese
konstitution relation die aber auch
schon ein bisschen den neologismus
betrieblich darf erinnern an dieses
verhältnis von männern und
personen bei lok das ist eben jetzt
große kritik ausgesetzt derrick walser
sagt zur konstitution relation zitat 100
andere stellen des relations riesen
nächsten tag eine stake out tours ist
englischer wörter überhaupt 6 in ein
ständiges allerdings zeitweise mit johan
persson interview mit einem kunden
nevilles belangte dürfen kainz nämlich
einmal 15 35 resistance kantischen one
of them but not that face tracking to be
carried out
als die unterstellung ist jetzt hier das
bk die these vertreten ihre konstitution
story dass das tier das uns konzentriert
eigentlich nicht denkt nur wir als
person eben denken dank der ersten
person passt
perfekt auf it hat einen ähnlichen
einwand gebracht der jetzt aber ihr die
luchse theorie des verhältnisses von und
carsten betrifft logins distinguished
queen persons and human animal der
jurist ingwer ebsen things zum song
human animal
instinct dort herrscht 25 enkels des
computers lebens erzählt nicole
kidman
also es kann eigentlich nicht sein dass
das tier denkt und die person denkt die
durch das tier konstituiert wird da
haben wir zwei banker zu viel becker
löst dieses problem nebenbei gesagt
dadurch dass sie sagen das tier denken
an einem abgeleiteten sind die personen
einem wesentlichen abgeleitet ich glaube
diese unterscheidung zwischen abgeleitet
denken und abgeglichen
das bringt nichts ende wieder wir denken
oder wir denken nicht ich glaube da gibt
es keine
modifikations möglichkeiten dazwischen
jetzt komme ich auf die personale
lebensform zu sprechen ich glaube wir
müssen also eine personal lebensform
entwickeln um dieses problem zu lösen
und dieses team managers programm und
normative signifikant unsere identität
als person gegen den animismus zu
behaupten also ich versuche jetzt für
eine personale identität theorie zu
argumentieren nicht jenseits von
animismus und konstitution alles muss
mit ihren jeweiligen probleme und dazu
ist es ganz wichtig zwischen
biologischer vom und biografischer so
mehr nicht die lebensform zu
unterscheiden diese unterscheidungen von
lebensform art von wo der erneuerung der
partie immer wieder gemacht wenn auch
auf eine andere weise wie ich jetzt also
zu machen georg köpfe sagt hier
überlebens fordert der begriff ist ja
auch völlig unklar wird manchmal sprach
philosophisch gebraucht bei wittgenstein
wird soziologisch gebraucht politisch
gebraucht er hat hier im biologischen
theologischen begriffen lebenslang genau
gesagt ökologischen er sagt eine
lebensform ist ein ökologisch
morphologischer typ von organismen der
als anpassung an bestimmte
umweltbedingungen entstanden ist
grundlage für die zuordnung von
organismen seiner lebensform ist somit
nicht ihre genealogische verwandtschaft
dass wir die art form sein ihre
ähnlichkeiten äußere gestalt und
lebensweise als manche philosophen
philosophen sprechen auch für
biografische lebensform im gegensatz zu
biologische art von weiteres zitat von
töpfer die lebensform betrifft die
gestalt eines organismus in der sich
sein verhältnis zur umwelt austritt
ihren wir wieder so leicht touristische
dimension
die die lebenserfahrung betrifft und da
sind sich jetzt anderen diese
unterscheidet von auto und lebensform
allerdings jetzt so dass die lebensform
nicht realistisch von der art von
getrimmtes ist da hätten wir wieder des
tui managers prozent sind wir müssen in
der individuellen person art von und
lebensform so integrieren dass erstens
eben kein tumani sinkt das problem
entsteht das ist die stoßrichtung gegen
die konstitution stil und de-mail
optimismus und zweitens auch kein
reduktionismus entsteht gegen animalis
muss der unsere identitäts bedingungen
qualitativ mit denen von würmern
gleichsetzen eben die normative
signifikanz jedoch zu unserer identität
als person
gehören scheint nicht berücksichtigen
kann unter logisch dazu sind jetzt zwei
schritte nötig für diese entwicklung der
personal lebensform wir müssen das
individuelle menschenleben komponieren
also die komposition relation da gehe ja
auch peter von in regen ein dadurch wird
die identität gewahrt
unter der haut fahren da spielt die
autonomie und dann müssen wir das nenne
ich jetzt konfigurationen in
figurationen müssen die personalie
lebens vor was genau das nicht gleich
noch mehr in das unter der haut von
individuell komponierte menschliche
leben ein bisserl müssen die lebensform
in figurieren und zwar zur vermeidung
eines pcs muss das heißt die lebensform
ist nicht reduziert auf die menschliche
haut fahren diese personalie lebensform
könnte auch von außerirdischen personen
exemplifiziert werden und sie dient eben
auch neben der vermeidung des pcs muss
auch zur auszeichnung zu normativ und
aussagen die person ja wie kann man das
jetzt genau verstehen ich sage jetzt
folgendes die personale lebens von ist
nicht so zu verstehen dass sie eine
separate form neben der menschlichen art
volk darstellt soll nicht mehr so dass
sie in dem sich reflexiv auf das leben
unter derart fazit und der aus
bestimmung gewinnt existiert also kein
journalismus dagegen möchte ich
argumentieren die personale lebensform
stellt also eine art intern rahmen da
der bestehende vermögen unter der haut
von also biologischer vermögen in sich
auf eine spezifische das heißt reflexive
und inter subjektive weise verbindet die
form betrifft die form der vermögen die
uns als natürliches individuen ausmachen
diese lebensform die unsere biologischen
vermögen konfiguriert in figuriert die
macht uns dadurch zu personen damit
stellt die kombination von integrations
und konfigurations redaktion eine
alternative jenseits von addition und
transformations- modelle die auch in der
gegenwärtigen debatte getreten werden
sie agiert nicht die personale
lebensform auf die haut vor dass ich
einen schichten modell von vermögen
ergibt dass man sagt da kommt halt noch
das vermögen der subjektivität die zwei
personen dass das positive nicht hatte
das traditionsduell noch ersetzt sie
diese
transformative das mache die
transplantation theoretikerin
theoretiker die sagen es gibt das tier
und dann entscheiden gibt aber das
bemühen der vernunft und dadurch wird
das ganze transformiert zu person
vielmehr bringt sie diese in figuration
redaktion die vermögen des individuell
unter der auch vom komponierten lebens
in neue redaktion so dass dies im
verbund auf einen neuen nämlich inter
subjektive weiß aktualisierbar werden
also hier in diesem verbund der vermögen
der neu konfiguriert wird da steckt das
personal das die lebensform als person
aus jetzt kann man sich das vor allem
formalisiert zu nehmen in anknüpfung an
peter van in wengen es gibt ein y die xe
komponieren y biologische aktivität der
xf ein menschliches leben kontrolliert
wobei die icsi materielle teilchen sind
das ist animalis muss das reicht aber
nicht dadurch hätten wir eben nicht
diese normative sind nur die ganze
person reicht wenn wir nur so person
decken würden wir brauchen noch diese
integrations relation dazu es gibt ein y
die fsg konfiguriert beziehungsweise im
figurieren y biom auf fisch wenn es die
vermögen von dem 12 erstens reflexiv und
zwar ist inter subjektiv ausrichtet
wobei elf die personal lebensform ist
und y das individuell unter derart form
komponierte menschlichen leben die ihren
wir bei diesen dieser formulierung
darüber
ja das war jetzt recht abstrakt jetzt
möchte ich das mal versuchen anzuwenden
auf
personenvereinigung
also juristische personen jetzt
abgegrenzt von rechtsfähigen stiftungen
die auch juristische person sind die
aber keine mitglieder haben darauf hatte
mich auch dank zweier weise gut ist im
gewesen als entsprechenden
personenvereinigung
kollektiv personen zeigen sich gegenüber
natürlichen personen wie menschen sie
sind da durchaus also nicht unmittelbar
als organische lebens lesen
charakterisiert werden können
beziehungsweise unmittelbar keine
natürliche art zu basis haben die sie in
figurieren doch besitzen kollektiv
person gleichwohl vermögen sie sind
träger von rechten und pflichten und sie
existieren auch individuell miteinander
klar abgebaut eigene stunde darauf hat
microstrom einem interessanten artikel
wie ich finde zu recht hingewiesen
jetzt gibt es zwei entgegengesetzte
auffassungen beziehung bezüglich der
identität von kollektiv person einmal
die funktions theorie die auch manchmal
so ein bisschen elementis muss gegangen
wird oder singular ismus da gibt es
dieses zitat sind künstliche durch bloße
fiktion angenommene subjekte da ist
dieser prominente theoretiker friedrich
grad von familien schon sehr alt und
dagegen gesetz ist die theorie der
realen verbandes persönlichkeit
kollektiv person oder die theorie des
zionismus bezüglich kollektiver personen
demnach die kollektive person als zitat
ein selbst tätig in die außenwelt
eingreifen das objekt gefasst wird und
demnach das menschlich gemein leben als
ein leben höhere ordnung betrachtet
werden kann dem sich das einzelleben
natürliche person ein leader zum ersten
ist das motto von gierke
ähnlich tennis und nicht ganz so aber in
die richtung des realismus der ist petit
darauf hat er schon ein redner
hingewiesen zuvor hing also hier finde
ich ganz in seinen details spricht von
leben höhere ordnung das ist mir sehr
sympathisch ich spreche auch sein
lebensraum
in dem sie das
als sie jede natürliche person
eigentlich ist der sympathische dies
aber nur die frage wie diese
eingliederung zu verstehen das hat
gibt's kirche nichts genaueres darüber
verlassen hat darauf hingewiesen dass
personen kollektive sich zur kollektiven
personen gewissermaßen wie ein
steinhaufen zu einem haus verhalten
finde ich auch zentral es geht hier um
eine organisationsprinzip die frage ist
jetzt nur wie muss da die individuelle
person integriert werden in die
kollektive person das ist die
ökologische frage an der alles hängt
jetzt
argumentiere ich das vitalis muss weil
dir gesagt die tat wir betrachten das
soziale ganze gleicht im einzel
organismus als ein lebendiges und ordnen
die im ein wesen zusammen mit den
einzelnen lesen dem gattungsbegriff des
lebens unter dass ich finde ich zu
vitalis tisch in der literatur wird auch
animismus genannt ich glaube hier ist
eine zunahme analogie zum natürlichen
leben ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
vier grad noch eine theorie und die auch
problematisch sagt nach der theorie der
realen verbands persönlichkeit gilt dass
die innere struktur eines ganzen des in
teilen menschen sind von einer
beschaffenheit sein muss wird das natur
ganze kein vorbild wird sagte jetzt
wieder dass hier ein geistiger
zusammenhang stattfindet ihr durch
psychische motiviertes handeln
hergestellt und gestaltet betätigt und
gelöst wird dass sie das reich der
naturwissenschaft ende um das reicht der
geisteswissenschaft beginnt also trotz
dieses vitalis muss sagte hier gibt es
eine art von geistigem leben soll jetzt
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
verhält sich dieses geistige leben der
kollektiv person zu hören
naturalistisch bestimmbaren
individuellen natur der der natürlichen
person und mir scheint das aus direktes
theorie ein too many fingers problem
zweiter stufe steht er hat die aktuell
ist er
sagt vielleicht die kollektiv person
reagiert da auf der natürlichen personen
da denkt die eine und die andere
ehrlich diesem turnier das problem hat
den dualismus und ich glaube das ist
unbefriedigend also müssen wir jetzt
einen mittelweg finden zwischen zu
schwacher funktions theorie und zu
starken theorie der ahlen verbands
persönlichkeit wie es in meinen augen
eben von guericke vertrieb ich versuche
jetzt hier wieder meine vorher
entwickelten kategorie anzuwählen diese
aber nicht auf die individuellen
personenzug auf die kollektive person
also das verhältnis von natürlichen
personen zur juristischen personen kann
im sinne der komposition relation
bestimmt werden da diese an identitäts
relation bezeichnet hier der weg lewis
hat darauf hingewiesen ich zitiere als
seele komposition der relations power to
the better than anyone relations auf
meine pace zu der mission es sei denn
die
komposition ist sollte das bip auf der
agenda gold ist sie es auf komposition
es alternativen
aktivität der natürlichen person als
personale lebensform komponiert die
kollektive person analog zur komposition
des individuellen lebens durch die
aktivität seine materieteilchen nun aber
eben nicht die biologischen sondern im
biologischen zu geben vorher entwickelt
haben man kann das folgendermaßen
formulieren es gibt tipps gehören die
echse komponieren y bio fisch wenn die
aktivität dix eine kollektiv person
konzentriert wobei ich die überbreite xi
natürliche person sind der unterschied
der komposition leistung von natürlichen
personen gegenüber materiellen teilchen
besteht darin dass natürliche person
bereits hinsichtlich ihres individuellen
lebens wurde der achsen durch materielle
teilchen komponieren zeit müssen
deswegen sind kollektiv person
komposition zweiter stufe jetzt
ausbilden möchte ich noch die frage nach
der normativität von kollektiv personen
aufwerfen
die verteilung von ämtern und funktionen
von macht und vermögen ist innerhalb der
kollektiv person durch die personale
lebensform bestimmt in sachen dazu
reflexiv auf inneres inter subjektive
norm geleitete verfahren der verteilung
reguliert werden muss also auch in der
kollektiv person trägt die
biologische personale lebensform auch
die ist dort vorhanden und die gibt dem
ganzen seine identität es handelt sich
bei kollektiv person also nicht um eine
in figuration die sich im rahmen des
lebens unter der anfang von ziehen dann
im rahmen der personal lebens von selbst
sofern sich jede probierte personal
lebens von kollektiv auf sich selbst
beziehen
korrektiv person sind deswegen so meine
these lebensform zweiter stock
allerdings und das jetzt eine
einschränkung gegenüber der natürlichen
personen natürlichen lebensform personal
ist die identität der kollektiv person
nicht in jeder hinsicht vergleichbar mit
derjenigen einer natürlichen person
ich spreche hier von einer achse
logischen identität halten die normative
die mission der kollektiv person ist
weitaus reduzierter zwar gelten für sie
nach dem grundgesetz auch grundrechte
soweit ihrem wesen nach auf diese
anwendbar sind paragraf 19 absatz 3
grundgesetz doch besitzen juristische
person jetzt geben im sinne der
kollektiv personen nicht im sinn der
stiftung keine absolute würde das heißt
auch kein recht auf leben bzw
kein recht ausbaut bestand also wäre
hier kein moralisches vergeben wenn wir
durch irgendwelche gründe jetzt eine
kollektiv person auflösen wird es hätte
juristische konsequenzen aber moralisch
wäre das nicht so zu bewerten die werden
wir einer natürlichen person ein ende
setzen die ihr sie zum beispiel typ
darauf hat sparplänen 2016 haben
hingewiesen ja das war es würde meiner
seite vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
ich verweise auf zwei aufsätze die ich
ein buch und ein aufsatz die ich
geschrieben habe
und zwar hier juni jefferson da habe ich
diese theorie sich mit blick auf
kollektiv person auch im blick auf die
individuelle person
thematisiert